كيف يبدو الوضع الان في الشارع الفلسطيني
حاله الترقب لرد الفعل من الفصائل
الفلسطينيه عقب العمليه العسكريه
هي كما قلت حاله كبيره من الترقب الشديد
والحذر ايضا وايضا متابعه كل التطورات
التي لا يوجد فيها كثير من هذه التطورات
حقيقه لليوم الثاني على التوالي الاجواء
كما هي السائد الوحيد هو اجواء الترقب
والمتابعه ومعرفه ما يمكن ان يحدث نحن هنا
في شارع منطقه الرمال في هذه المنطقه تعرف
بمفترق السرايا الحكومي وهي منطقه من
الاكثر حيويه
واهميه وازدحاما ايضا من حيث الحركه
المروريه سواء بالمركبات او الافراد
باعتبارها منطقه تتضمن اكثر المحال
التجاريه اهميه والمؤسسات الحكوميه
والاهليه والخاصه ووسائل الاعلام ولكن
ربما تشاهدون في خلفيه الصوره الحركه تكون
على نطاق ضيق جدا بسبب هذه الاجواء
الكل يترقب ما الذي يمكن ان يحدث خلال
الساعات القادمه وهذا الشعور يسكن الشارع
الفلسطيني منذ يوم امس او منذ الاعلان عن
عمليه الاغتيال اغتيال القاده الثلاثه من
سرايا القدس الجناح العسكري لحركه الجهاد
الاسلامي هنا المؤسسات الفلسطينيه الرسميه
في قطاع غزه بالتاكيد اعلنت عن اجراءات
امنيه
استثنائيه لمواجهه ومواكبه اي شيء يمكن ان
يحدث واعلنت عن تعليق الدوام في مختلف
المؤسسات الحكوميه الرسميه الخاصه الا في
حدود نطاق دنيا جدا وفي في حدود يعني
المؤسسات التي يمكن ان تقوم بخدمه المواطن
الفلسطيني على نطاق ضيق اعاده انتشار
عناصرها بالنسبه لوزاره الداخليه طواقم
الاسعاف هي الاخرى مستنفره وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه على اهبه الاست الغت البرامج
الروتينيه والعاديه والتي كان مبرمجا لها
ان تحدث في مختلف المستشفيات في قطاع غزه
لكنها توجه نداءات متكرره واخرها هذا
اليوم عندما قالت بان هذا الوضع واغلاق
المعابر تسبب في منع او حرمان اكثر من 140
مريضا كانوا ينوون السفر اليوم الى
المستشفيات القدس والضفه الغربيه لتلقي
العلاج الان الغيت هذه الحجوزات ومنعوا من
السفر ناهيك عن بعض الجرحى الذين يحتاجون
الى اجلاء ايضا لتلقي العلاج نظرا للوضع
في قطاع غزه وكل هذه الاحداث وهذه الاجواء
تنعكس على المؤسسات الاخرى على سبيل
المثال المؤسسات التعليميه اغلقت بالكامل
والمؤسسات الاقتصاديه هي الاخرى بعض
المحال التي تتعلق بضروره فتح ابوابها لكي
يتزود المواطنون
بالمقتنيات الاساسيه المواد الغ ومشاكل
ذلك بقيه المؤسسات هي في حاله شلل تام اذا
حاله الترقب هي السائده لليوم الثاني على
التوالي والكل يحاول ان يلتقط ما يمكن ان
يرشح ويصدر عن الفصائل الفلسطينيه من
تصريحات او تلميحات من بيانات من تحليلات
ما الذي يمكن ان يحدث لكن حاله الصمت
المطبق وحاله الضبابيه هي التي سادت حتى
على كل التصريحات التي صدرت عن الفصائل
الفلسطينيه التي تتكتم بشكل كبير حتى الان
عما يمكن ان تحمله الساعات او الايام
القادمه اكثر من ذلك بعض الاوساط اصبحت
تتحدث عن امكانيه ان تستمر هذه الحاله
الضبابيه لايام وليست لساعات بما يتصل بما
بمسيره الاعلام المجمع انعقادها
الاسرائيليه المزمع عن عقادها في القدس
بعد نحو ثمانيه ايام تقريبا وبالتالي يمكن
لل الفلسطينيه ان تقوم بحاله استنزاف
بمعنى انها حولت هذه الحاله الضبابيه
وحاله الصمت والترقب الى ما يشبه معركه
الاستنزاف من الناحيه المعنويه ومن
الناحيه العمليه ايضا
للكيان الاسرائيلي ولصانع القرار
الاسرائيلي وبالتالي هذا اصبح يتردد في
بعض الاوساط ويحلو البعض ان يقول بان
الفصائل الفلسطينيه يمكن ان تؤجل الرد الى
ايام اولا لتحاول البحث عن هدف يمكن ان
يشكل ردا مناسبا للجريمه التي حصلت كما
يقولون باغتيال ثلاثه من كبار قاده سرايا
القدس ثانيا
لقلب كل النتائج التي كان يريد نتنياهو
الحكومه الاسرائيليه ان يراكموها ويسوقوها
كانجازات كبيره جدا تضاف الى رصيدهم
تتجاوز وتحقق انجازات سياسيه وامنيه
واجتماعيه ايضا في اسرائيل
ويحاول الفص ان تحولها الى خسائر بالجمله
لهذه الحكومه كلما تقدمت عقارب الساعه الى
الامام ومضى يوم اخر باتجاه مسيره الاعلام
بالتاكيد هذا سيكون بمثابه حرب استنزاف
ويمكن تحويل الانجاز الى خساره ويمكن ان
ربما تدفع حتى
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الى التسرع واتخاذ
بعض القرارات والتحرشات الميدانيه للضغط
على الفصائل الفلسطينيه
واستفزازهم من اجل دفعهم لاتخاذ اجراءات
ما لكن حتى الان الوضع السائد والراهن هو
هذا الصمت المطبق على الارض